[Music]
hey guys what's up Derek with Advanced
love Automotive welcome back to the
channel welcome back to another video
now as promised before on my channel I
did tell you guys that I was gonna start
doing some videos getting more into the
locksmithing and key programming side of
the industry I've recently discovered a
passion with this side of the industry
I've been doing it now for almost a year
and I want to show you guys some of the
things that I've learned so maybe I can
help some of you guys that are
interested in getting into this field
not one of the most common questions
that I see asked over and over again by
aspiring locksmiths is what equipment
should I buy what is the best key
programmer where should I start so in
this series of videos I'm going to try
and help you guys decide what key
programmer slash key tool is best for
you now I will preface this video by
saying there is not one key programmer
that does everything so if you guys are
looking for that magic bullet that one
key programmer that just does everything
well I got bad news for you guys it
doesn't exist in this industry you're
going to find out that you pretty much
are required to buy many different
programmers in order to cover as many
vehicles as possible but what I hope to
do with this video is give you guys a
starting point show you guys the tool
that I use for almost 90 percent of the
vehicles that I program keys for so over
here in my toolbox as you guys can see
I've got all of my most commonly used
key programmers and key tools starting
over here on the left I have the X tool
ik618 over here I've got the autel im508
over here to the right we've got the
launch x431 emo plus over here I've got
the xhorse key tool Max here I've got
the key DIY kdx2 and I have my xhorse
mini key tool however the one I want to
show you guys in this video is this
little bad boy right here this is the
autel km100 now unlike the im508 the
km100 was designed to be more of a
portable handheld key tool but let me
make this clear the autel cam 100 is not
a complete substitute for the im508 if
you guys are looking to do more eprom
work and keys for European cars the
im508 coupled with the XP P400 is
probably going to be your choice however
for the majority of cars here in North
America the km100 is going to be able to
do a majority of the vehicles on the
road plus it has some built-in features
that does not come with the im508 and
they have to be purchased as an extra
add-on so with that being said let's
delve a little bit deeper into this game
100 and find out what it's capable of
now before we dig deeper into this tool
I do want to take a quick moment to show
you guys everything that comes in the
kit when you buy it so first of all we
have the unit itself which is roughly
about the size of my iPhone and so it's
a very portable unit and it's also about
half the price of the iPhone over here
we have the Bluetooth wireless dongle
that also has a built-in light so if you
push this button it's got a little
flashlight in there to help you find the
OBD2 port you also get this cable which
is USBC to USBC in order for you to
connect the dongle to the unit in some
applications it will advise you to
connect it using the wire there are some
vehicles that you don't want to program
wirelessly so always make sure to have
this cable at the ready over here as you
can see they give you a charging cable
and a charging block the kit also comes
with two Universal IQ these are
universal Smart keys that can be
generated to many different applications
they also come in various button
configurations we're going to get a
little bit deeper into these later on in
the video over here we have the cable
that's used to do remote renews which
basically allows us to unlock previously
locked keys some smart keys on some
Vehicles will become locked whenever
they're programmed to a car and so
before you can reuse it and program it
to another vehicle you may have to
unlock it that's what this cable is for
now this really only applies to OEM keys
not really aftermarket Keys which by the
way if you guys are going to be using
the universal eye keys there really is
no need to unlock the keys these can be
regenerated over and over again as many
times as you like so even if you program
this to a car and then something happens
maybe the customer doesn't want this key
so you want to be able to reuse it on a
different vehicle you can absolutely do
that all you have to do is regenerate
the key using the tool so now we know
everything that comes in the kit let's
go ahead and dig deeper into the unit
all right guys so here's the main menu
as you can see we have quite a few
different functions so starting up here
at the top you can see we have our
Universal key that is to generate our
Universal eye Keys now I will get a
little bit deeper into these because
these Universal eye keys are actually
really awesome and they can save you a
ton of money especially when it comes to
having to inventory keys but we'll get
into that a little bit later in the
video next up you can see we have
reading and cloning which is basically a
function that allows you to read the
chip inside of the key and also clone it
over here we have a transponder function
which we can use to generate
transponders over here we have a
frequency detection where we can test
our remotes down here we have the emo
function which is the immobilizer
function that's what we're going to use
in order to program the keys then we
have some more special functions down
here we'll get into that in a minute let
me start off by selecting reading and
cloning so basically let's go in here
and we're going to read a key it's
instructing us to put either a chip into
the chip hole right here or put your key
into this hole so right now I have this
key for a Chevy Cruze let's go ahead and
stick it into the slot right here and
then we're going to hit read it's
reading the transponder inside the key
and here we can see all the information
about this key up here you can see we
have a chip model we have an emo type
it's telling us it's a high Tag 2 id46
it's giving us a transponder ID the lock
status which basically tells you whether
or not the key is locked this key is
programmed to a vehicle so right now if
you wanted to try to reuse this key on
another vehicle you would first have to
unlock it which means you'd have to open
it up take the circuit board out use a
special function in the key tool along
with this cable like I mentioned before
unlock the chip then you can reprogram
it to another vehicle now as far as
cloning the chip in this key basically
you drop this in there and we're going
to hit clone now this is a transponder
46 so whenever you clone these Keys it
does require that you do a password
calculation so what the tool instructs
you to do is put the antenna of this
tool up against the ignition coil I'm
referring to the antenna around the
keyhole where you stick the key in it's
going to detect the coil around the
ignition then it's going to calculate
the password and allow you to write it
to a clone chip now here's where it's
asking you to put the tool up against
the ignition coil you can see that's the
key going into the keyhole and
essentially every time you insert the
key and turn the key on there's a signal
that's being passed back and forth
between the Chip And also the antenna
the autel is going to pick that signal
up it's going to calculate the password
then it's going to allow you to clone it
to a chip so we've got the key tool
pressed up against the ignition coil I'm
going to go ahead and stick the key in
turn the ignition on
and we may have to do this a few times
so key off take the key out put the key
back in turn it on
do it again
basically just do this until it tells
you whether or not it acquired the
signal
there we have it it is now calculating
as you can see it calculated our
password so that was just a brief
overview of the cloning function of this
tool next up I wanted to show you guys
the transponder function so if we click
on that you can see up here at the top
we have transponder generation so this
is where you would generate a
transponder so if you go down here let's
say a Ford 4d63 if you wanted to
generate one of these chips of course
you would have to buy whatever chip
works with this tool so if we back out
this second option here is pretty cool
this is a transponder simulation and so
basically what this allows you to do is
use the tool to simulate a key chip now
moving back to the home page let's go
ahead and click on frequency detection
this is something very useful especially
if you have a remote that's not working
and you're not sure if the problem is
with the remote or with the vehicle you
can just use this function to test the
frequency of the remote so I'm going to
go ahead and unlock this you guys can
see how it just registered the frequency
and it tells us what frequency the key
is so I'm going to click it again
you guys can see this remote is 315
megahertz now we're going to go into
special functions and here's where
you're going to find a lot of cool
different things that you can do first
of all you can do key unlocking again if
you guys have a key an OEM key that was
previously locked to another vehicle you
can use this tool to renew that key so
here we're in the Dodge menu let's just
pick any of these you can see they give
you a little diagram right here of how
to connect to the circuit board using
the supplied cable you basically have to
solder to the points on the board then
you hit unlock and it will unlock the
key now another function that you can
use this for is unlocking Toyota Smart
keys this function is very easy to do
you don't have to open the key there's
no soldering involved you basically just
stick the key into the slot up here hit
unlock and it will unlock the key now
let me warn you guys Toyota Keys
starting from 2018 2019 and up a lot of
those keys cannot be unlocked I know
this personally because I ran into one
on a 2020 where I use the key tool to
unlock the key and even when I use the
key tool to read the key again it showed
that it was unlocked however it would
not program back into the vehicle on
those newer Toyotas once the keys are
locked they're locked for good another
function that you can do here is you can
do button adjustment which basically
means that if you generate a universal I
key and program it to the vehicle and
for whatever reason the button
Arrangement is not correct let's say
when you push the lock button the doors
unlock and when you push the unlock
button the doors lock and you need to
switch those button Arrangements all you
got to do is take the key Stick it into
the slot select the button adjustment
and you can switch them around however
you like okay so I have another
Universal I key that has a battery in it
and so we're going to slide it in here
we'll hit retry it's detecting the
universal remote and here we have our
button functions again you can see that
the unlock icon is unlocked the lock
icon is lock remote start is remote
start the trunk button is the trunk and
the Panic is the Panic so again you can
go in here and you can move them around
so let's say that you wanted to move the
unlock button and make it the lock you
could just select lock and then you want
it to make the lock button the unlock
button you can go in there and select
unlock and now all you have to do is
confirm writing and this will write that
button adjustment into the key you can
see it's writing it right now and now
you can see that the unlock icon is now
the lock button and the lock icon is now
the unlock button you can also do
combination buttons where if there's
another function let's say like a
convertible top and your key doesn't
have that button you could do a
combination where in this case if you
push the remote start and the trunk
button at the same time you can make it
work for let's say a convertible top
lots of really cool stuff that you can
do with these Universal eye keys and
just as easy as it was to change the
button configurations you can just as
easily restore the initial value by just
clicking here and it restores everything
back to the way it was now another cool
special function that you can use is
this ignition coil detection this is
useful when you have a vehicle that's a
no start and you're not sure whether the
problem is in the key or the antenna
coil on the vehicle so if we select
ignition coil detection all you got to
do is take the antenna on top of the
tool right here put it up against the
antenna on the vehicle put the key in
turn it and see whether not you're
getting a signal very useful to have
some other special functions that you
have are these Mazda id49 smart key
warning lamp clearings basically on some
Mazdas when you program a key to them if
the key is not the exact or correct FCC
ID or the correct button Arrangement or
sometimes if it's an aftermarket key the
vehicle may still start and run with the
key but you're going to get a light on
the dash this function is used to help
you get rid of that light there's also a
function for the Nissan Infiniti and
there's another Universal key bot
adjustment I'm not exactly sure what
that does guys but if you need it it's
there now moving into the immobilizer
side I'm not going to go too much into
detail right now because I am going to
be showing you how to program a key on a
Nissan later on in this video but
basically when you come in here you can
see that you have all different
manufacturers that you can program keys
for everything from domestic import
Europeans the list goes on and on if you
guys are not sure about compatibility
you can go on to the autel website and
they do have a compatibility chart where
you can go in there put the tool that
you're working with the make and model
and see what you can and cannot do with
it we also have a selection here for
automatically identifying the VIN now I
will mention that the tool works best as
long as you're connected to the internet
so wherever you're going to program Keys
make sure you take a Wi-Fi hotspot with
you a lot of times I just use my phone
as a hotspot and that usually works good
enough so now that we've covered
everything else let me take you guys
into the big reason that I love this
tool and that is the universal key
generation function basically what this
allows us to do is it allows us to
generate over 700 plus FCC IDs for all
different makes and models of course
this function only works with the autel
universal eye keys but the selection of
I Keys is really awesome I'm going to
show you guys here in a little bit my
inventory of autel keys these here are
just the basic design but they do have
these keys in OEM form that look just
like the OEM keys but before we get into
that let's go ahead and click on the
function here for Universal key now
here's where we can find the key that
we're looking for you can do this a
couple different ways you can put in the
VIN number you can put in the license
plate number or you can just come in
here and put your make and model so
let's go ahead and select a Chevrolet
we'll choose a model let's say a
Trailblazer and we'll choose a year
2020. you can see the reference FCC ID
number is a
hyq4ea that's what the key originally
looks like now autel does have a
universal key that looks pretty similar
to this one it's not the exact same one
it's the one for the Cadillac but I've
had a lot of luck selling the Cadillac
style to people who have this type of
key but even if you don't have that key
you can always use just one of these
Universal keys so let's go ahead and
generate it I'm going to select it it
tells us to go ahead and put the
universal key in the slot now of course
you want to make sure that you put a
battery in your key these keys do not
come with batteries so you do have to
buy them now we're going to go ahead and
select generate Universal key
it's acquiring the universal key
information and now it's generating our
key
okay so our Universal key is generated
that probably took about a minute or so
so here when you're done you want to
just go ahead and hit completed and now
our Universal I key has been generated
it is now ready to be programmed to the
vehicle like any other FCC ID with
hyq4ea it is that simple guys like I
said the cool thing about these Keys is
that they are reusable you can generate
them as many times as you like so if I
want to back out of this menu and
generate this key to another FCC ID I
can do it no problem even if I program
this key to a vehicle and it becomes
locked to that vehicle let's say there's
a problem with the customer maybe the
payment didn't go through you already
programmed the key and so you want to
take your key back it's no problem all
you got to do is stick it back in here
and regenerate it and the key will be as
good as new and ready to use on another
vehicle that's something you cannot do
with OEM keys or even aftermarket Keys
okay guys so just a quick overview of
some of the keys that autel offers in
their Universal format these are some
keys from my personal inventory like I
said I stock all different kinds of keys
for lots of different makes them models
but what I love about these Keys is that
they do offer them in the OEM shell so
here we have one that's a Nissan style
key now I do have this in the four
button configuration without the remote
start and also the three button
configuration I'm not going to open up
all my keys to show you guys but
basically this here is a universal Smart
Key and can be generated to work with
over 700 different Vehicles using an
autel device like this one now
technically you can generate these
Universal Keys using the im508 however
what I like about the km100 is that it's
way more portable it's a lot easier to
use you don't have to pull out the
separate attachment which is the XP 200
pull the cable out connect it to the
unit in order to generate your Universal
key you can simply just pull out this
unit Slide the key in here of course put
a battery in it first select your
Universal key and then generate it now
the reason I love these keys so much is
that when it comes to inventory and keys
for example let's say Nissan you might
look at a key for a Nissan Altima and a
Nissan Maxima and the key looks exactly
the same however the FCC IDs of the keys
and the part numbers are actually
different meaning that you couldn't use
a key from a Nissan Pathfinder on a
Nissan Altima typically they're going to
be different FCC IDs so rather than
having to inventory one of every FCC ID
that there is for Nissan you can simply
have one key and be able to generate
that key to work with whatever vehicle
you're programming the key for all you
got to do is look up what fccid is the
correct one for the vehicle I usually do
this by going online and looking through
the catalogs usually uhshardware.com is
a pretty reliable and accurate source
for looking up what type of key your
vehicle needs find the correct FCC ID
for your make and model then find that
FCC ID in the autel generate your key to
that and then program it to the vehicle
that will save you tons of money in
inventory now not only do we have the
Nissan style we also have this Hyundai
style of course these keys do come with
the emergency blade so make sure that
whatever you're using it for uses the
same emergency blade here we have the
Dodge style this is the five button
configuration I also have the four
button configuration now the other cool
thing about these Keys is that even if
you don't have the correct button
configuration you can buy the correct
shell for the key that you're looking
for take the internals out of this key
and move it over to your new shell here
we have the GM style key which is the
Cadillac stock very high quality key
very beautiful indeed a lot of people
have no problem taking this key rather
than some of the older Cadillac keys I
like to sell these as upgrades because
typically those older Cadillac keys they
start to fall apart really easily and
these keys well they're just better made
then over here we have the Honda style
key this is one of the ones that I sell
more often again people like the style
key and so even for some of the older
style Hondas when I offer them this
newer style they prefer to take this one
again the cool thing about these Keys is
that yes you can change the shell in one
instance I had a customer with a 2021
Acura and they prefer to have the Acura
style key and so basically I generated
and programmed one of these keys and
then I took the internals out of the key
and then I put it into an Acura shell
just to show you guys this is the shell
for the Acura key so there is nothing
inside this key but essentially what you
can do is take the guts out of this key
and it fits right into this key these
shells can be purchased really cheaply
online and are good to have whenever you
have a customer that is a little more
picky and they want the key that looks
like their original key just a quick tip
for you guys also I will add that the
auto Universal I key for the three
button Nissan only comes in this button
configuration which I'm not exactly sure
why because I've never seen a Nissan
that has this button Arrangement
typically if it's a three button this
button down here is going to be a panic
button a lot of the vehicles like the
Nissan Rogues and the Jukes don't have
an electronic trunk so it's typically
just a panic button here however it's no
big deal I still like to buy these
because all I do is I buy the shell for
the three button key that I need all I
got to do is take the internals out of
this key and move it over into the shell
now over here we have the BMW fem style
key which is a very beautiful high
quality key and it is required in order
to generate some of these BMW keys Oops
I did leave out one key which is this
Buick style key this is also a universal
eye key so this can be be generated from
many different Vehicles here at the top
you can see I have a few of these
Universal eye Keys these are the generic
styles that autel offers they do come in
a lot of different button configurations
and I pretty much inventory all of them
now I'm not going to go through and open
every single package to show you guys
you can go online and look at all the
different button configurations that
they offer but just know that these keys
do not come with an emergency blade so
when I pop this open what you're going
to find is that we have a slot right
here and also a little set screw right
there and what these are designed for is
for you to be able to use Flip Key
blades as emergency blades now I'm going
to be getting a little more into detail
when it comes to flip keys and Flip Key
blades in another video but just know
that yes you can put emergency blades
into these Keys now one key that I am
kind of leaving out is this Ford key
right here this is a very special key
the reason I say that is because this
key is the only key out of all of the
autel keys that you can generate it to
the 900 megahertz frequency now contrary
to some of the things you might read
about these keys and them being able to
work for 900 megahertz it is not true
you cannot generate the 902 megahertz
key for the Ford with any of these other
Universal Keys you have to have this key
now the problem with that is that this
key is kind of elusive I can't really
find it locally or really anywhere in
the US when I check with my key
suppliers they never seem to have these
available however you can buy these
online from places like AliExpress these
in particular I did get while I was on a
trip to Mexico I was in Mexico City for
the auto mechanical event and one of the
vendors there sold these to me but like
I said guys if you run into the Fords
especially the ones that have remote
start those are typically the higher
frequencies like 902 megahertz you
cannot use any of these keys to generate
that you have to have this key so now
that I've shown you guys some of the
available Universal keys for the autel
let's go ahead and generate one and
program it to a vehicle alright guys so
we're going to be generating a key and
programming it to a 2022 Nissan Altima
not what I like to start by doing is
going online to a website like
uhshardware.com punching in the make and
model of the vehicle that we're going to
be programming a key to and finding the
correct FCC ID for the key we need to
generate so on the tool we're going to
start by going to Universal key we're
going to select Nissan
for the model we're going to select
Ultima for the year we're going to
select 2022. again the important thing
is that we find the correct FCC ID and
also the button configuration now this
vehicle originally does come with remote
start however the customer bought this
vehicle from a used car lot and the key
that they gave him was a key without
remote start so obviously at some point
in time they had lost the keys and
whoever sold them the keys sold them a
key without remote start now the key
still functions and everything however
the customer does want the remote start
function because of course his car comes
equipped with it now I did already
successfully add a key to this one the
remote start works great however the
customer did call me back because now he
wants a second key so that's what we're
going to be doing today so we're going
to scroll through these FCC IDs and
we're going to locate the five button
remote start key that has fccid
kr5tx N4 there's our key right there as
you can see it is the five button with
the remote start and so before we can
generate this key we are going to have
to put a battery in it again these
Universal keys do not come with
batteries so you do have to buy them
separately in this case they use a
CR2032 battery so we're basically just
going to take this part of the shell
we're going to pop in the battery then
we're going to take the other half of
the shell and then we're going to put it
together line it up correctly
then just pop it back together
now our key has a battery in it and it's
ready to generate so we'll go ahead and
drop it into the slot and hit generate
Universal key
as you can see it's generating our key
this should only take about a minute or
so
key generation is completed and now our
key is ready to program to the vehicle
okay guys so 2022 Nissan Altima again
I've got the km100 right here you can
see I've already got the Bluetooth
dongle connected and over here on the
center console I've got three keys now
this one here is the original Nissan key
that's already programmed to the vehicle
and this one is an oxtail generated ikey
that I already programmed everything
works great and this is the key here
that we're going to be adding now the
way we're going to do this today is
we're going to do an all keys lost
situation that way we can erase all of
the previous keys that were in the
memory that no longer is with the
vehicle and so basically we're going to
be starting fresh we're going to go
ahead and start by going into emo
then we're going to select Nissan
Right Here Nissan
let's just go ahead and do automatic
selection
it's telling us to turn the hazard
lights on so we'll go ahead and hit the
hazard switch the hazard lights are now
on and it wants us to open and close the
door I'm going to go ahead and hit OK
it's scanning the vehicle system okay so
I'm going to go into IMO status scan and
here it's going to scan the modules and
if you look there are no dtc's present
in the BCM so we're going to go ahead
and do all keys lost guided I'm gonna go
ahead and shut the vehicle off
our hazard lights are still on and we're
going to go ahead and hit start and it's
going to obtain the pin number it tells
us execution of this function will erase
all keys so make sure you have all the
keys that you need to learn to the
vehicle ready we do so we're going to
click yes turn the ignition off turn on
the hazard lights and open and close the
door we already did that so we'll hit ok
now here it's giving us a little warning
this is our BCM code that it pulled up
and it's letting us know that if we have
one of these other BCM codes then
attempting this programming may be risky
some of these bcms can actually lock up
or become bricked just by doing the PIN
code reading and so you need to make
sure that your VIN number is not part of
this Blacklist now if you guys didn't
know you could go online and Google
Nissan BCM Blacklist you're going to
find a set of numbers and those are
going to be the bco numbers you want to
stay away from again our number here
does not match any of the ones on The
Blacklist so we're going to go ahead and
click yes
now it's telling us to place the
original smart key up against the button
so this here is our original I key I'm
going to put it up against the button
just in case you guys didn't know our
ignition button is right here make sure
you have it where the emblem is right
where the button is we're going to go
ahead and click OK establishing
communication okay so success it pulled
the PIN code now it's telling us to push
the ignition switch and put the key that
you want to learn up against the button
so I'm going to push it
and you can see the instrument cluster
just came on and if you pay attention
the security light went off that is a
good sign so we're going to go ahead and
hit OK turn off the ignition so let's
push it again
ignition is off now we'll hit OK program
success continue to program the next one
yes we're basically going to do the same
thing with the next key so I'm going to
put the next key up against the push
button then we're going to push it once
the instrument cluster comes on and pay
attention to that security light you see
how it went away that means our key is
now registered so we're going to hit OK
it says turn the ignition off so we'll
turn it off instrument cluster is now
off and then we're going to hit OK
program success continue to the next one
yes now we're basically going to do the
same thing with our final key this one
here put it up against the start button
and we're going to push it
push it once instrument cluster should
light up
and pay attention to that security light
right there
it just went away and so we're going to
hit OK
it says turn the ignition off
ignition is now off and we'll hit OK
programming success continue to the next
one no now it's telling us to put the
first key that was learned up against
the button that's going to be this
original Nissan key so we'll put it up
against the button and we're going to
push it once
the instrument cluster should light up
instrument cluster came on so we'll hit
ok now it says turn it off and wait for
three seconds so we're gonna count to
three and you can see we already have a
message here key registration complete
and so now we should be ready to hit OK
programming complete check if remote
control is operating properly start the
engine and wait for five seconds so I'm
going to hit OK
and we should be done here with the tool
yep so we have success there all the way
around now I'm going to go ahead and
shut the hazard lights off then I'm
going to open and close the door then
we're going to check to see if our
remotes work so we'll start with the
original one lock
unlock that works we'll go ahead and try
the second one so lock
and unlock
that works
and then we'll try the third one lock
unlock now let's go ahead and try to
start the vehicle so foot on the brake
pedal hit the start button
and car starts up right away and just
like that we're done all right guys so
before we end off the video a couple
things I wanted to mention about the
tool number one is that this thing
actually comes with the built-in apb112
if you guys aren't familiar with that
basically what it is is a key simulator
and it can be used in order to do an all
keys lost situation on a newer Toyota
now the apb112 is an item that has to be
purchased separately if you guys have
either an im508 or the im506 they do not
come with the tools when you buy them
and the simulator is usually somewhere
between two and three hundred dollars
now the simulator is really useful if
you run into an all keys lost situation
on a newer Toyota the newer Toyotas
require a 12-digit rolling pin code and
so what you can do on some of these is
actually read the eprom information by
OBD using the tool then with that eprom
information this thing can actually
simulate the key that was programmed to
the vehicle so you can actually start
the vehicle with the antenna on this
this also allows you to add a key easily
on these newer Toyotas by simulating the
original key and then using that to add
the second key so really cool feature to
have built into the tool like I said if
you guys have an im508 or an im608 it
does not come with it you have to buy
the apb112 separately with this km100
it's built into the tool now second
thing I wanted to mention if you guys
are buying this tool in order to do
cloning by that I mean cloning of
transponders let it be known that the
vvdi Superchip from xhorse does not work
with this tool I know a lot of guys get
confused because that's really the most
popular chip that's on the market
however the vvdi Superchip does not work
with the auto now as far as what chips
do work with the odd cell I'm not
exactly sure though I have seen several
videos of people actually cloning chips
with this tool so I know that there are
some chips on the market that do work
with the autel I'm just not exactly sure
which ones other than that this tool is
one of my top five favorite tools that I
have in my possession this is easily the
first key programmer that I go for
anytime I go to program Keys simply
because it's so portable and easy to use
now will it do everything no but it does
do probably 90 of the vehicles that I
program keys for and for for the rest
that this thing can't do I have several
other tools for that and all those other
tools are a lot more expensive than this
one now if you guys are interested in
purchasing this product I will leave a
link down in the description below I do
want to let you guys know that I was not
paid to review this product I'm simply
giving you guys my honest opinion and
showing you all of the features that it
has now if you guys do decide to buy the
product using the link below any
purchase that you buy through that
Amazon affiliate link does go to help
the channel so thank you guys for all of
your support anyways at this point I'm
gonna end out the video like I always
say thank you guys for watching I hope
you found the video useful informational
educational entertaining if you did make
sure to give it a thumbs up if you
haven't done so already make sure you
subscribe to the channel hit that
notification Bell and I'll see you guys
in the next one thanks
[Music]
thank you